[Music]
are you a student journalist educational
institution diplomat NGO or interest
group have you a specific interest in
the EU if so why not come to the
European Commission's visitor center
each year we host over 1,800 groups
that's over 50,000 people and help them
to better understand the role of the
European Commission and how it can help
them
[Music]
we offer options on what you can see who
you can meet and what you can learn
through a unique package of visitors
experiences I'm a first year law student
but studying for a degree in Bachelor of
law honors at the University of Malta I
learned a lot about competencies both of
the EU and the work of the Commission
within the structure of the
institution's our general information
visits are an ideal way to gain a good
overview of the European Commission's
history and its role in today's
political landscape for more specialist
groups we offer a policy specific visit
this is designed to provide your group
with a more detailed policy led
information package often employing top
Commission officials to talk through
policy and current issues on a European
level you know occasionally I will when
year the Euro hope don't affect Amanda -
she do declare some function more every
year
- to scheme in this position new new
journalists accompli original regardless
at a song we also provide tailored
information visits for groups focused on
specific tasks or operating in specific
industry or policy fields at either
national or international level I would
say that this is or if it isn't it
should be part of our job description to
be available to meet these groups
journalists and sometimes students that
come visit the institution's it's also
the
an invaluable source of information for
us to get feedback on what we are doing
and how we are doing it and sometimes
you you are asked things that make you
rethink the way you are doing things so
the it's a huge added value and we
should really make an effort to to
engage as much as possible if you
represent an organization or team and
would like to attend one of our
information sessions apply for your
visit at our website
[Music]
you